on va dire sofer bonsoir vous êtes
ambassadeur d'israël c'est à dire que
non seulement vous représenter israël en
france et en plus comme on est
ambassadeur de france
chaque fois que vous allez à l'étranger
vous êtes toujours ambassadeurs d'israël
oui en effet j'ai gagné ce titre la
dignité de l'ambassadeur d'israël il ya
deux ans mais je suis ambassadeur depuis
18 ans a en france pourtant d'autres et
on y viendra repris à vous êtes né en
irak d'une famille bourgeoise assez
riche et vous avez été obligé de fuir
l'irak après guerre en traversant ces
marais où aujourd'hui il ya la guerre
non oui c'est tout son époux qu'elle
j'appartenais la communauté juive d'irak
et la communauté le plus ancien des
communautés juives d'une famille
bourgeoise et puis je me suis trouvé à
l'âge de 15 ans comme poursuivi pour un
crime qui était considéré dans le temps
comme le ne plus la plus gande crime
qu'on peut commettre c'était d'apprendre
l'hébreu
vous avez été surpris en train
d'apprendre l'hébreu j'étais surpris et
puis j'ai je devais quitter et on a
promis à mon père que dans le temps à
donner la somme d'argent pour franchir
la frontière
dans quelques heures et puis ça durait
trois semaines dans les marécages là où
il ya les champs de bataille entre
orange irak élit aujourd'hui oui et je
dois dire que c'est un des miracles que
je suis en face de vous très bien nous
sommes ravis de vous avoir alors vous
publié chez laffont un livre qui
s'appelle le diamant noir et qui raconte
un peu votre vie tout cette époque lira
que le l'arrivée en israël votre
réussite dans le commerce
et puis votre décision finalement un
jour de tout de tout quitter pour servir
israël et vous êtes nommé attaché
d'ambassade en centrafrique avant d'être
nommé ambassadeur au tchad abrite
quelque chose qui m'intéresse beaucoup
parce que j'avais eu connaissance du
projet de herzl d'installer il sera
elles n'ont pas en palestine mais en
ouganda et j'avais imaginé dans un livre
que finalement qu'est ce qui se serait
passé si israël avait été installée en
ouganda alors moi c'était du roman mais
vous comment avez vous vécu cela est
compensé vous de secours
je dois dire que dieu merci que ce
projet n'a pas été réalisés parce que en
ouganda le peuple juif n'avait aucune
racine donc nous serions dans une
situation très difficile
alors que dieu merci nous avons établi
notre état dans un état dans une terre
qui nous appartient avec une longue
histoire avec des racines et lorsque je
suis arrivé en centrafrique
j'ai vécu le moment des pionniers
d'israël en afrique nous avons amené
avec nous l'esprit pionnier nous avons
avec amener avec nous les raccourcis
pour le développement nous étions nous
nous sentions comme une seconde aire de
pionnier en israël nous avons vécu comme
les africains
je dois dire que lorsque j'ai décidé de
tout quitter pour aller dans la carrière
diplomatique évidemment on pourrait
penser que c'était une vie en noir un
départ et puis je me suis retrouvé avec
des chauffeurs jim dans des jeeps avec
un ambassadeur qui m'accueille en
ceinture qui était un cordon fille ses
regrets comme ceinture pas de fast nous
avons et nous nous sommes installés dans
une écurie qui était transformée en
domicile parce que l'ambassadeur était
un membre de quibou tu voulais à
implanter l'esprit pionnier d'israël en
a fait des corrections de ne rien rater
de in auditive abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou